question do you think it's weird that we
like listen to ourselves often
like because we have to hear our voice
all the time yeah i think that's weird i
mean it was weird when we first started
off right because
people at home have you ever listened to
your like your voice recorded you
probably hate it right
i'm assuming right i mean i've never
grown out there yeah you're yeah you're
still
if anyone should be grown out of it it's
you i i
i hate looking at my own like hearing my
own voice looking at my own content
like whenever i do a collaboration with
someone i watch like the bare minimum
just to get what's going on and then
like i i watch every moment of that
collab that i'm not in
i'm just like oh i'm in it skip skip
ahead ah okay okay you're like you're
like in the comments timestamps please
of when i'm not
why wait so why though like why why can
you like i mean okay maybe
maybe it's the better question ask why
can we stand our own voice because
that's probably the weirdest idea
because you just got used to it right i
mean like yeah i don't think anyone grew
up
right and like ever ever went into that
situation i'm sure every family
had it where your parents would just be
like you know what there's nothing
really to watch oh i found some home
videos we can watch those and you're
like
no thank you because i don't know i
always
[ __ ] hate it when my parents would
play home videos in france oh
yeah yeah yeah this is always me being a
[ __ ] idiot yes but it's also
it's also but it's also like the i used
to have like a [ __ ] squeaker voice
when i was like five years old
i legitimately used to sound like hi
guys
and my dad would always [ __ ] rag me
on me like man your balls really dropped
all the time
and i [ __ ] hated that because when
you're a kid you're not aware that you
have that voice
no right because everyone is the same
voice around you exactly exactly and you
grow with your voice so you don't
suddenly be like
oh my voice got deeper unless it's like
a really
rapid growth like finally yeah yeah
you're just like your [ __ ] [ __ ]
dropped
yeah i i thought when it i thought when
it happened i thought it was gonna go
back
i thought it was like i thought i was
sick or something all right right and
everyone at school didn't believe me
yeah but that's because your balls
dropped like a [ __ ] cannonball right
like
mine kind of dropped yeah mine kind of
dropped like you know it's
just like putting like a rock in water
it's just it's just a very slow drop
that's a very slow joke well you know
what i mean it's like
because you grow with it especially if
it's a natural drop
then you don't realize that oh i went
from [ __ ] alvin and the church
we were really talking about speed our
balls drops now yeah
so you don't watch the podcast at all
after we i like that
you don't watch trash taste wow i i
watched like some highlights
i i don't know like i because i feel
like with me i'm just
super self-critical and i've always been
this way whether it be with my work
or myself and that's why like i'd say
like i've i've seen
anytime i see like criticisms of my
videos and my work i'm just
i'm more fine with it because there
hasn't been something that's been said
about me
that i haven't already said about myself
in some way shape or form
so unless i'm like super proud of a
video i really
i find it difficult to watch it because
i see all the things that
i kind of could improve on it or that i
[ __ ] hate about it
it's just out there i can't like so
you're too much of a perfectionist
basically
i don't like from one i hate the word
perfectionist but you are a
perfectionist
and i like this i'd prefer the term
self-critical
a self-critical perfectionist is what
you are essentially
because like you have an editor but you
also
edit your own stuff too right like
everything yeah you always do like the
finishing touches yeah i always do the
finishing touches
and like when there's a collab where i
have zero control over i'm that's just
like i wake up in a cold sweat but i'm
not like
what if i just look like an [ __ ] on
this one oh you know it's
oh wait so then how do you get through
your editing process because you have to
listen to yourself right over and over
and over again
yeah so are you just like cringing
internally as you're like ah i need to
edit this
cause you you're doing like you know you
you had jokes you had punch lines yeah
do
you not like think damn that was a good
delivery i nailed that delivery yeah and
sometimes i listen to a joke and i edit
it for like three hours and i'm just
like this joke's not funny anymore
and i just cut it and it it's it's it's
a weird thing where
depending on how my mood is my video
could just be completely different
like i could i could just be watching
myself and i'm just like i hate i hate
this part i'm gonna just
re-record this entire segment even
though it's gonna add like two three
hours to my [ __ ] video making process
and then i do it see that's why i'm glad
that i got an editor that has comp
that i gave complete creative freedom so
because i'm pretty sure you were talking
about this earlier but like
at least with my editor uh he leaves in
[ __ ] that i
would have otherwise cut out no that's
that's what i like i i tell anyone i
hired edit for me i'm like
i don't care how bad it makes me look
yeah just make it funny yeah like
please make it funny because because the
at least right you're going to get the
draft right and you're going to check it
and if it's really [ __ ] bad then you
can just tell them to cut it out but a
lot of the times
it's like oh i in my head i was i
thought this was not going to make it
into the video but he kind of
twisted it in a way where it's like oh
you know what that's kind of a funny bit
i never thought about
yeah like where i like fail a joke and
i'm like let me do that again yeah yeah
they leave that in yeah that's just the
joke yeah mean i guess it's like the
difference between like heavily scripted
content
and more like improvised content because
there are times when
i think i have like a [ __ ] banger of
a joke and then i watch it like 30 times
as i'm editing it
and i have to like question whether it
was funny in the first place or whether
i've
seen it so many [ __ ] times that it's
just lost all like
comedy comedic effect to me the the
reason i asked that question earlier was
because i i saw a video i don't know i
don't know if it was a ted talk it
sounds like a ted talk topic but
it was something like people everyday
people should just like
record their voice and listen to it so
they can improve their speaking in
general to be more confident right
yeah because that theory was that your
overall
general quality of life in like doing
anything in daily life
improve drastically if your speaking is
more confident
like if your voice is more i agree with
you i would agree with that and i think
in general definitely like if there's
been the one big thing in my life that
has
done me solids it's it's the voice tip
yeah
and talking you know for sure yeah just
going at it i don't know
and i maybe think a lot i'm like oh yeah
i guess i'd never really thought about i
mean obviously
you know people say oh you have nice
voices yeah not to stroke my [ __ ]
dick but
you know that's the compliment i get the
most right and i thought you were good
voice
that's the reason i became a voice actor
because people were telling me like hey
you have a nice voice and i thought
yeah [ __ ] you know you're what you're
right
damn i i do kind of i'm kidding because
when i first recorded myself i thought
it sounded like [ __ ]
and then everyone thinks that though
right right but then it's one of those
things where i think that
it's definitely helped me a bunch
because not only have i improved my
enunciation and just general
patterns of my speech it just made my
whole life more confident by
doing that yeah because you have general
self-confidence yeah because
because if i'm hearing it i'm like damn
i sound good yeah
is that conceited as [ __ ] no no no no no
i mean i mean
it's just you just you get a skill set
by practicing it right i mean like
and even if you get happy with the
ability that you have to like
change it and make it sound the way you
want i think yeah and like i feel like
even just being on trash taste and just
like
like i don't watch every episode that
i'm in but like i still
will have to watch like certain clips
just to check in and everything like
that
and i feel like especially my speaking
skills has gotten a lot better
i've gotten a lot better i of course i'm
so on point
as soon as i say that you really drove
that point home gone thank you